[موسيقى]
ما لديك هنا الآن هو
حقًا مفهوم
تم تصميم هذه الكبسولات لاستيعاب أكثر من
2000 شخص ، وقد تم
تصميم هذا خصيصًا هنا لدبي وما
لدينا هنا هو قسم من الدرجة الأولى
هنا وبعد ذلك  قسم الفصل القياسي
هنا هو تجربة شخصية
أعتقد أن الناس ينسون أحيانًا أنك تعلم
أننا كل شيء عن السرعة كل شيء
يتعلق بالسرعة لا يتعلق الأمر
بكيفية سفرك في المستقبل سواء كنت
ترغب في السفر في الوقت الذي تريد
السفر فيه
كثيرًا  من بين هذه الأنظمة الممكنة التي تحتوي على أنظمة معلومات وترفيه
، فإن قدرة نظامنا
على التعرف على من تمر
عبر الأمان تأخذك من خلال
إرشادك لتعرف أن الأمر كله يتعلق بالحصول
على تجربة شخصية في الوقت الذي
تجلس فيه في مقعدك حتى أنظمة المعلومات والترفيه
تعرف على ما
تفضله وقم بوضع ما تريد سماعه
عندما تريد أن تسمعه ، فنحن ما زلنا في
مرحلة التطوير من هذا النطاق ،
وليس لدينا أي شيء ، فهم يأخذون الكثير من
التخطيط  من خلال
الابتكار ، التخطيط الدقيق
والتطوير مقدمًا قبل أن نبدأ في
إنفاق مبالغ طائلة من المال ،
يجب أن تكون أنظمة النقل الجماعي
لقسم الأعمال ، لكل ما لا يمكن أن تستند إليه في
الانقسامات التي يحتاجون إليها ليكونوا قادرين على
الوصول إليها من أجل القيام بذلك.
كن وقائيًا ، يجب أن تكون قادرًا على
تسعير نظامنا بحيث يكون
منافسًا لوسائل النقل الأخرى ، نعم
قد يكون هناك علاوة لأنك تحصل على
هذه الفوائد الضخمة ولكن في النهاية
نحتاج أيضًا إلى فهم أننا بحاجة إلى
تحقيق إيرادات وأن هناك
خط دقيق للغاية بين قدرة المستهلكين
على تحمل التكاليف وعدم تحملها ، لذلك نحن
حساسون للغاية لضمان أن التسعير
يعكس الحاجة إلى جذب الجميع